Last question.
Okay.
Thanks.
Also for continuing the electric series.
I haven't listened to all of the lectures,
but it seems like you focus very much
on the appeal of the biblical stories to
the individual psychology.
Do you have any thoughts on the relative
importance of crowd psychology to the
uh,
appeal instinct?
However,
the Bible and also the,
the reason why the Bible or the biblical
stories took precedence over other,
um,
ideologies which could
have taken its place.
Okay.
Well,
let's go to the second one first.
I think it's the same thing
that happens when someone,
okay.
Both creates an edits,
a great movie.
Okay.
It's no one knows,
like,
imagine how many choices are
they're in a great movie.
Let's say it's an animated movie because
absolutely everything in an animated
movie is constructed.
Everything.
There's,
God only knows how many choices.
Like maybe there's millions of choices,
you know,
and each choice is guided by
some intuition of narrative
suitability or beauty
or there's some higher
ideal motivating it,
right?
The desire to produce a masterpiece.
Maybe that's it.
That was certainly the case
with the Disney movies,
for example.
And so that that aspiration
then then makes the decisions.
And so I would say,
well something like that
guided the writing and the
selection of the stories in,
in the biblical Canon now
could have there been other stories
included while the Catholics and the
Protestants don't have the same biblical
tradition and neither do the Jews and
the Christians.
And so it isn't exactly
clear what to make of that,
you know,
I mean that's a can in some sense to the
discussion we just had about Islam and
Christianity.
Um,
in some sense I've left that aside,
that specific question except in so far
as I've just answered because I'm trying
to take what we have,
which I know is that the root of our
culture and to figure out what it is that
we have,
why it is that we have it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well I've made some attempt to explain
that in the manner that I just described,
but I don't have a final answer.
Like could it have been different?
It could have been
different at some levels,
but the same at others.
You know,
I mean,
one of the things that's the scholars
of comparative religion who haven't been
infected fatally with postmodernism
have definitely realized so young,
for example,
in Elliott and people who are
interested in grand narratives,
one of the things they pointed
out quite clearly is that there's,
there's,
there's a set of common
mythological themes across many,
and I tried to outline
that in maps of meaning.
And that worked out quite nicely for
me at least as far as I was concerned
because once I had the basic
archetipal structure mapped out,
it opened up all sorts of stories to me
from all sorts of different cultures.
And that's been unbelievably useful.
Like the Mesopotamian story of it,
the Enuma Elish when,
when I figured out what that
meant as far as I was concerned,
like I've never forgotten that.
It just seared itself into my memory.
And the same with the
Egyptian stories and you know,
some Buddhist writing said,
I've read it in some,
the Tao Te Ching is also very powerful.
So I think that things can be different
on one level and that same metta
another,
but that humanity kind of coalesces on
what's the same over a reasonable period
of time because there isn't that many
ways that human beings can live properly
as individuals and as groups together.
And so there's this constant force
that makes our ethical presuppositions
converge and then that's automatically
expressed in the stories.
It's something like that now.
It's an imperfect process
and it's full of error.
So.
Yup.
[inaudible]
so
one announcement,
uh,
well two announcements.
The next lecture I
believe is November 14th,
so I'll hopefully finish
off the story of Jacob,
looks like it.
And then I'm also appearing on a panel
with Gad Saad and or an amateur Jay on
November 11th and there's still quite
a few tickets available for that.
So if you're interested,
you could go to my website
and pick up those tickets.
It should be,
well,
hopefully it'll be interesting.
I think it will be and it
might be too interesting.
That's one possibility.
So we'll see.
But I'm going to do two
more of these this year,
and I hope I get through the story of
Joseph and then I can start in the new
year with the exodus.
And that's a story that I know quite well.
And the exodus and Leviticus.
And what's the one after that?
You,
yes.
Thank you.
Um,
so I'm very much looking forward to
that because that is one killer story
mountain,
so,
and I've got some
surprises for that as well.
So anyway,
so thank you very much for coming.
And,
uh,
hopefully we'll see you November for
14.